okay uh is it 10 almost 10 yes
10 enough
okay uh first up
we have house bill 1028 relative the
form of individual health insurance
policies
so this is is this the short-term one
do i get the right bill
okay
does anyone want to speak for this bill
anybody think this is a good idea
okay so uh just to
remind everybody about this one this is
the one that um
i think turcotte turcotte was the one he
yeah introduced and this one has the
idea that we take these short-term
policies which we do have one company
that actually does sell this product
and is designing to be um
so uh like in between if you're in
between jobs or something and if you
just want a quick policy
but it does not have any of the rules of
of um
what i would call senate bill 711 but
obviously we now have
obamacare or
affordable care act whichever you want
to call it
which this this statute would be in
total violation of
because it doesn't it it has
pre-existing condition requirements
so
obviously that's not a good idea
since you can go into the individual
market
is it called the marketplace what's it
called marketplace now
and get a subsidized plan um but
obviously if you're
you don't hit the income brackets i
guess you
you might not get the subsidized but
i'm pretty sure you're not going to want
to buy a health insurance plan that that
is going to make you feel out of medical
form
that have you tell them everything
that's wrong with you
which is a fundamental of a short-term
policy
okay yes
maybe is this a question for the chair
or maybe it's
someone has expertise on the issue
that you have people have a long period
of unemployment and they'll go on to the
marketplace healthcare.gov
and their income is actually so low that
they wouldn't get wouldn't be able to
get into a subsidized plan and they get
shipped out how can that be what's that
your if your income is too low
you don't get that plan you get moved
over to medicaid
and the problem or they suggest that you
get medicaid and then some i've had
constituents apply for medicaid and they
can't get it for some technicality or
reason so that's why i've thought of
short-term plans as maybe like a backup
backup if things really go south then
you're just going off the city it is
available for that you know you could
get it but you
at the end of the day you the
technicality needs to be corrected i
mean i don't
i mean i i
you have to give us a real life story of
how
medicaid doesn't cover somebody you know
i've heard of people not filling out the
form correctly
they're not giving the pay stubs or but
if you have no
income you have no income
i mean how could how what technicality
could you be refused on i well i mean
when i when i've gone door-to-door doing
citizens petitions or campaigning
um they'll get you know i i can't even
remember the whole litany of excuses
people been given why they
have officially their income is too high
because somebody else has income or they
live with other people or whatever they
can't they can't get medicaid and they
can't get
uh obamacare so the only thing they can
get is a short-term
plan until
they get a permanent job that's cut
where they're covered that they're
at work so there's because of household
they're in a household they could be so
so it would be going off topic to get
into why peop in my opinion why people
are disqualified for medicaid but
there's there are thousands and
thousands and thousands of people with
no income or very low income who cannot
get medicaid
you guys ever heard of this
yes holly
yeah when you come up here in the mic
thanks
thank you chairman for the record holly
stevens director of public policy at
nami new hampshire
i think the state would be very
interested
to hear
the issues that your constituents
have had
because with
granite advantage which is the medicaid
expansion program that we have
it's strictly based on income
and if you're below 138
of the federal poverty level you
automatically qualify they do not look
at assets there's no asset test for it
and it's based on your individual income
so
if you've got a son who is 30 living
with
his parents
the parent's income doesn't count
against
you know so it wouldn't wouldn't
disqualify that person from being able
to get medicaid so
i would
highly suggest that you reach out to
the department maybe henry lipman
let him know what you're hearing because
that's extremely concerning if there are
thousands and thousands of people who
qualify for medicaid expansion
and they're being turned away
then we need to do something at the
department level
i i just think it's getting off topic
and i for the short term plans i just
think
it's kind of a it's kind of a safety net
if they've got nothing else and they
just need something to cover them for a
certain time
well that short term is available for
that but what i'm i'm
but don't ever think that you want to
take it for long term
because as soon as you make a claim they
cancel you
okay i mean there's obviously a market
for short term
and it's it's usually for people who are
disabled or out of work or some other
issue
yes tyler you want to tell us who are
the people who buy the short term
it occurred to me that the issue that
those constituents might have faced
would have been before the aca or before
new hampshire did a medicaid expansion
because medicaid was limited years ago
to people who had who were low income
but also had something else think sort
of women children that type of thing but
with the expansion you did away with it
those types of limitations so i think
maybe they're sort of thinking
historically there was a problem they
tried to sign up for medicaid and were
unable to i think it's also important to
point out that the legislation doesn't
actually
change whether or not we're going to
have a market for short-term policies
the language was was attempted to make
them less short-term but either way i
think vote the bill you know you don't
need to pass the legislation to continue
to have these plans available to people
in new hampshire
okay any other questions
all right so we have
hunt bartlett greeson
terry
burrows and ammon
and you're here
okay
so um
anybody like to make a motion
i'll make the motion all right
representative bartlett the motion would
be itl
okay
listen all this says exactly
um
oh
uh
okay
um
uh
okay i don't have the sheets so we're
gonna have to uh she's gonna
we can use that
yeah
i like these ones better
okay representative bartlett
and
the second
second representative grayson second
sure
okay
so the motion is uh in expedient to
legislate all those in favor please
raise your hand
okay
next up 1162 relative to requiring
insurance coverage for vaccinations
devices medications authorized for
emergency use by the united states food
and drug administration
1162.
so
do we have any evidence that this is
actually occurring at all or
that well we only had one time this to
happen right
mr chair i have this as um
exp i mean it's interim study six to
zero okay so we already
but i don't have who made the motion
yeah i uh we'll i'll i'll get the file
okay okay so we already we already took
care of that one
all right and that was
interim study
okay
moving right along um hb 1245 relative
to co-payments for services rendered by
chiropractor
so
um
i think i think we should just study
this issue um
in a little more
everybody feel comfortable with study
yeah
okay
mr chair i i mean you and i
talked about this and i think we've
talked about it among our our caucuses
that
we understand that
this could be a problem for some people
but that um
our feeling is
that
it really is a
negotiation between the
chiropractors and the insurance
companies
is that the way you see it as well yes
exactly
but i mean to me you actually have to
shop your insurance company
right because it i mean what i found out
was when i was talking to the sponsor
that anthem it's 40 and harvard is 30.
and i think one of our difficulties i
think one of the difficulties we um i
have identified is that
um
they're being
um classified as specialists
but that it really isn't up to us to
determine if they're a specialist or a
pcp
right
is that the way we see it
um
in terms of who is determined what they
are
i don't i don't think
i mean the only
there is a case actually now that i
think about it
that a chiropractor could be a
naturopath
and i'm looking at you now tyler
and a natural path can be a primary okay
we because we i think if i wrote the
statute correctly i think i said may
so that there could be an insurance
company that would
treat
that
chiropractor if that chiropractor was a
naturopath and was their primary care
physician
they could get away with no co-pay but
are we legislating that we've already
done that we already did that
that we made
well that was chiropractic that was one
of my rare occasions where i was able to
drop in the word may right
what a memory you've got to mr chair um
so this was legislated that naturopaths
may be
classified
as a primary as primary care and
how did that affect chiropractors so
because some chiropractors are natural
paths
okay
then that
should give them more argument with
their
well
i would say the vast majority are not
natural paths but
that that is just a little twist to the
to the storyline but
okay so i'm fine with the normal study
yeah representation i think the
continuing discussion at this time is
uh ample evidence that we need to
continue to study this
uh i also think that that we
we owe our constituents
some of whom i have heard from who are
in support of this bill
we need to be able to formulate a
response
to them that they
can understand
which i don't think i can do that right
now so i i think just begs once again
for interim study okay and i know we'll
do that seriously thank you all right
all right so the motion uh
representative bartlett second by
representative seconded by
representative terry moves uh
interim study any discussion on the
question of all those in favor please
raise your hand
2 3 4 6 0.
12.45
okay
next up 15 uh relative insurance
coverage for pandas
um well as it turns out the sunset
doesn't occur for another two years so
there's no
particular hurry for us to do this bill
and and we're still
feeling our way through the the claims
history right tyler we're still
you might need to come to a mic i'm
sorry
yes that's correct so the claims that
are not particularly insightful at the
moment because there's not a specific
diagnosis code for pandas although we
understand there is one that is under
development and planned to be
implemented so at a future point in time
we would be able to use the claims that
it attract that the pandas patients much
better than we can at the moment
great thank you
okay
um so i'd entertain in in exp motion
anybody would like to make the motion
what's that
um
you want to discuss it some more sure
yeah
i i just i think
really all this bill does is take off a
sunset clause that the senate put on
after we passed this through our
committee last term
well maybe it's more than that it's
going to be three years three years ago
all this bill does if you read it is
they had put the sunset clause in to
repeal this
july 1st of 2024 right so that would
have been that's all we're changing here
is just taking the repeal off so people
who are enjoying the coverage
will be able to continue to do that and
if we if we take the sunset clubs off
the insurance it will
remove the requirement for insurance
companies to provide the coverage so
that's two years from now
well agreed but we can't there's been no
evidence to suggest that this has
increased any premiums or there's been
any negative effect to this so i don't
um
i don't understand why we need to wait
well there was some question whether the
law was really necessary that that
we don't really know if there really was
a problem
well i'd
i think we were all in agreement there
was a problem when we all passed the
bill in the first place well not all of
us voted for it okay
well it but it did pass and and it's
true that that we've certainly um had a
tremendous amount of testimony that this
particular treatment
did help
a certain population i remember there
was some debate about the treatment
but it left
the decision to be made by the person's
specialist or care
medical
person not us which is appropriate we
shouldn't be making decisions for what
treatments should be
doctors should be
so
and i think that we argued over this
quite a bit and
it was very clear that in the bill that
it wasn't our decision that it was up to
the medical profession to decide
what was appropriate so
you know my fear on this one is it's
going to slip underneath the radar and
disappear and we're going to have a lot
of people who are going to be hurt by
this when they
the
requirement to provide the coverage goes
away
i can assure you that the sponsor has
already committed to putting this bill
in again next year we'll keep putting it
in
so
it's not going to slip through the
cracks we just want to make sure that
when if we decide to uh
really repeat the sunset
that we have good evidence that the
statute is necessary
could could we amend the motion to
interim study just so that future
legislation would
be beyond the record that at least our
committee um feels that this is a um
a worthwhile discussion to continue okay
representative bartlett
second by representative greeson
maybe it's more of a parliamentary
inquiry i also agree that the legislate
maybe not the legislature but the state
needs to do something about this issue
because it's important enough to do
something about but if we're going to
say we want to put it on the record i'm
wondering if it
to actually put it on the record like
the house journal wouldn't that be
something where you kind of make a
motion on the floor or someone just says
you know as a committee we've agreed
that something needs to be done about
this and then just add that to the house
journal
well it would be when we put it in the
calendar for why we're keeping his
interim study
okay would you like to make the motion
when we take it up for the full
committee and you can write that blurb
somebody's well when i said uh we had a
bill on hydroelectric dams and i just
kept writing this damn bill is necessary
because yada yada and then the
house clerk took all that language out
and nobody laughed
if we if we give it an interim study
certainly you know that allows the
future like
future legislation to um look at the
file and
um
consider that we felt that it was worth
continuing the discussion you want to do
something about it said and i just have
i have a feeling that somebody else is
probably also going to volunteer to
write this because it's
it's something that a lot of members of
the committee care about i'm glad to
write it i think representative bartlett
will win and as rich lambert points out
i'm the only legislator who has to when
he does his financial disclosure
documents that i own a dam
and yes it's a damn damn shame that i
have to pay twelve hundred dollars a
year for
licensure fees
you should have seen the article this
morning about the the durham old mill
dam who's in the paper
okay all right so all those in favor of
interim studies raise your hand one two
three four five six okay
thank you
mr chair i also have six to zero itl on
this one we already we already see okay
yeah unfortunately i told her to just go
ahead and put all the ones that was that
day
and i had forgotten that we had actually
okay so my memory is not so perfect
sometimes
so i have to write everything down okay
so that's already itl what i don't have
is who made the motion yeah that'll be
in the file
okay last but not least 1503
i do have something i want to hand out
to everybody
of course this subcommittee is different
yes
you took any kind of business course you
had to read it
everybody who had to read this
everybody
and who wrote this um
draft
chair is there a page
and you wrote you wrote this mr chair
who wrote this
this was handed to me by the bankers
association by the new hampshire bankers
association okay this is new hampshire
bankers association hand this to me
and and
it goes on probably says more of the
same maybe
because why don't you just come in and
introduce you know what you where we're
reading here just so people know what
there's nothing better to do on new
year's eve
good morning thank you mr chair um i did
not write this um i just shared it as i
thought it might be helpful um this was
information that was shared from folks
at the uniform law commission so um i
did not see that the obviously it's only
got a page one there i can go back and
see if there's a second they're
additional it could be who knows how
many pages there could be but the key
element is the first couple of
paragraphs there yes i just wanted to
share that in case it was a helpful
resource for you all i know it's a very
dense issue so this was their draft you
can see when they dated it um for last
year is just for why they believe that
states should adopt
um chapter 12 to the ucc and i mean when
they wrote this i'm assuming they
intended states to adopt it once it's
been finalized which isn't yet although
close so just providing it as a resource
so i can't take credit but i will try to
find additional pages
yes
uh yeah thank you for taking my question
it's not actually a question it's a
statement um i have here the uh um
executive order
2022-1 from the governor
uh establishing the commission on
cryptocurrencies and digital assets
and the report on this is due out august
8th
so
my feeling is that we should
just put this aside until we hear from
the governor's commission
um which is sounds like it's going to be
a very good group of people who all have
knowledge with the subject
and see what he has to suggest
thank you chris
um
okay so here here's the situation
and and yes if you want to represent
foreign is that going to be released
obviously
well then
interim study will allow us to wait to
get that report
and come revisit this that would be my
suggestion i could support interim study
okay
so
here's here's where i stand on this bill
and that is i've been on this committee
enough times to have have reviewed and
done ucc legislation
the whole point of ucc legislation is
that
everybody passes it every state passes
it
that's the point of it
i have to be
honest
and admit
that
in normal course of events in normal
sequences
i would say
let's wait another year
let's wait to next year
and
that way
we know we'll have the official language
and everything is
all the eyes are dotted and the t's are
crossed
but having knowing that
and knowing that we have a timing
sequence here in terms of
this bill would still need to be go to
the senate
and
the governor can veto it
if anybody else thinks this is premature
and not the right time to pass it
and i'm balancing that off with
the fact
that i was never
overly
happy
with the fact that we have absolutely no
regulatory authority no guidelines we
got nothing
when it comes to
blockchain
transactions in the state of new
hampshire
what this ucc bill does
is creates
the guidelines
for anybody who is actually harmed
by crypto technology
if somebody is harmed by it
they would use
this statute if it were passed
to pursue
a lawsuit pursue trying to get their
money back
so if you democrats and i'm pointing to
you now
think
that it's not worth
trying to put something in
in effect right away
to protect consumers
protect people
and you would much rather just sit on it
for another year because if we don't do
it that means this won't be in law until
year and two months from now
if you think that is
that we should only be commerce and not
consumer affairs and not give the tools
to help consumers if they are harmed by
this technology
and lord notice i had nightmares last
night thinking about all those little
numbers and blocking and i just i had
kept waking up thinking that i
that
how did they how does this technology
work i just it's beyond me it's very
scary
and if i know that we have an
opportunity
to be the first state to say
it's here
but we want to make sure our
constituents
have the tools that have the protections
to ensure that these transactions are
done correctly
i have another problem with the bill
and that's in the first section which is
about um
the which was part of the original bill
uh about the um
exemption for securities
saying that it would not be treated as a
security
and it's it's about the secretary of
state's fee which is a hundred dollars
per filing
in wyoming it's a thousand dollars per f
per filing and i'm wondering why ours is
so
low and whether or not that's going to
be enough
to cover the cost of this
well since the secretary of state
is not actually enforcing or doing
anything and all they're doing is being
a registered
agent you could say well why don't we do
it like a non-profit and only be fifty
dollars
but a hundred dollars is a standard
transaction we have for businesses
and all it is is that they are recording
that it exists
and so therefore that again
that is a key element of the protection
that we're not getting you anything
other than
uh
in terms of the person who's having a
lawsuit if there's is that
i was sold a product that was not
properly registered
so whether it's a hundred dollar or a
thousand dollars we certainly don't want
to do a thousand dollars if we're not
going to actually do any enforcement
that would be an unfair use of fees
so are you saying there won't be any
enforcement the enforcement no that is
correct
yeah yeah excuse me yes that is correct
the enforcement of this legislation is
private right of action that is already
been stated that's already been done by
this committee we are not expecting
departments
because remember this is a commodity
we're not expecting the department don't
we usually ask for enforcement when we
when we make a law
what's the point
like i said
is that under our consumer protection
act
we have created the private right of
action triple damages
and that can be anything
when the consumer has been harmed
outside of the four exempted agencies
my feeling still is that this is a
dangerous industry i think that it's
rife with all kinds of fraudsters and i
personally don't think new hampshire
should be first in the nation to put out
the welcome met no it's not the welcome
mat this is absolutely not the welcome
mat at all this is saying is if you're
going to do do this activity
there's an expectation
that you are going to do it
appropriately
and this is the same appropriateness
that everyone else in the country is
eventually going to pass
representative mccleary
the way i read this is this is does not
necessarily commit
commit us to anything because this is
simply saying that should we decide to
proceed
we have the
certain regulations in effect so ground
rules i i don't have a problem with this
because it is not
thin a it's not done thank you all right
okay
representative amen who's the sponsor
so i was just going to read into the
record
some of the sentences in this
recommendation the last sentence of
first paragraph a state should adopt the
amendments to facilitate modern
commercial transactions involving these
technologies
and avoid obstacles and lack of clarity
under current law
inhibiting the transactions or
increasing their costs so the ucc the
universal uh
law commission is recommending that
states adopt this no of course it's
draft but
do we want to be part of the pack and
not have an advantage or do we want to
be a step ahead
on
this
technology it's this technology is going
to change it's currently changing the
world this is
this is not beanie babies this is the
next internet i know what it is
and so trying to paint it with uh
you know the brush of criminal activity
every technology is amoral
you can use a knife to cut a stake you
can use a knife to stab someone you can
use a car
to get groceries or to get away from a
bank robbery
same with the internet so trying to
paint a technology with with morality
doesn't work
it's the same thing with nuclear weapons
right
or nuclear technology this is a
technology
it's earth
changing it's societal changing and i
think new hampshire does want to be out
in front of this
our industry our banking industry our
regulatory department
will have
a head start on every other state by
getting up to speed on this
change that is coming so
it's a matter of like being
forward-looking or being stuck in the
past
representative anderson's next it's just
a point of information uh in criminal
law and civil law indefinite sorry in
definitions
voice isn't too loud today in
definitions and whatnot um
the way things have always been since
colonial times is every issue or every
question in a lawsuit or something like
that is first handled under the common
law which is how the courts interpret
natural law so if you're wronged or
harmed in such a way you cur you have a
cause of action
unless the legislature comes up with a
law like the criminal code only took
effect in 1973 before that we were under
common law you know common law murder
common law rape common law arson that
kind of thing so
there in my opinion that there is
currently a
process and it would just be going to
the superior court to actually sue
someone
if somebody had a cause of action
so the question is
do we want to
for members the actual question i think
is do we want to just let the courts
continue to run with this or do we want
to
kind of step in and have a say
so i think that's what it kind of comes
down to
representative burrows
thanks and this is really just an open
question which is you
mr chair you you talked about how
complex this is and in
cryptocurrency is new to many of us so
my question is
this is what i'm grappling with is this
above our crate our pay grade in terms
of the complexity and the understanding
of it to leave this to a commission that
might include people who are expert
in this field and i'd be curious to know
your take on that
um
i have no idea what the purpose of the
commission was
and what the governor had in mind
um
i i i would tell the governor that stole
his not made in russia but
doesn't stop him from doing what he
wants to do
so i mean i i i've read that read the
general purpose was just just a you know
the type of study
but that did did it actually say
um
that you know in terms of you know what
proposed legislation or what's going
forward there's no doubt in my mind that
every member of that commission would
tell you
first thing you do
is pass this bill
so if you want to
move the process along
then you pass the bill if you want to
delay it another year
i mean yes that commission comes out but
it doesn't mean they're doing anything
until it comes to the legislature which
won't happen until next january
so we would not have anything in effect
until
july
of 2023
representative bartlett thanks mr chair
so we know there's another amendment
that's going to come along correct we're
not going to deal with that today
so what we're voting on is not really
what's going to be final anyway it's in
the end of the day this is going to be
at the senate you know a month from now
the senate will then have that decision
to make uh to
take up and clean up the
statute to clean up the statute well
the problem we have is we don't really
know exactly what we got with this red
line version
because it seemed to be taking the notes
and rolling it in and just commenting on
it so
we need tom conley
and tom conley is in santa domingo and
drinking margaritas so we can't do much
about that right now so my feeling is
that i just i hate to lose this
opportunity to you know get in front
on something as important as something
that i am having yes trouble
understanding and the sooner we get
something going on the books the sooner
they will all understand what the heck
is going on here with this technology
but
you know
the whole idea is why would you delay
guidelines
if you know this is where the where the
nation's going
because we don't usually put stuff on
the books that i grant you that
that isn't going to be what's going to
be put there we are the last new england
state to pass the marijuana legislation
we are plenty of times we're not the
last but there are times we've been the
first well we certainly haven't been the
first on cannabis but i don't think
that's part of this discussion okay well
how about how about the lottery we were
we were the first with the lottery so
you know there are times you can be the
first certainly grown
nobody nobody has a problem with the
lottery nobody has a problem with the
lottery
oh okay a lot of people think we should
get rid of it let's not say that well
you get rid of people think we should
get rid of a lot of water that you're
you're obs um
well i'm boy i'm using i'm losing the
word um at any rate let's go back to the
amendment okay um
i mean i have a problem with
our passing something we know is not
going to be what's going to happen
uh as far as i can read into it
it is not that much different than what
we have in this amendment
and that it would uh the
if there are and there is it seems to be
some more reference references and
reference points
that is uh certainly appropriate for tom
conley to have it fixed and have us
recommend to the senate to go forward
with the bill could could we but i hate
to just say just put the brakes on it
right now and say let's wait another
year could we ask christy merrill to
come up and talk about the possibility
of
another amendment
we could certainly ask chrissy how what
what she knows okay
because this this draft that we were
just provided with
doesn't
address the changes that have happened
since
december 31st
so why don't you tell us chrissy what
that really happened
thank you representative christy merrill
new hampshire bankers i'm going to see
if i can just pull up the email quickly
that i received um i did receive and
share a um
an amendment from the latest version
which i understand is incorporated in
the amendment before you all today and
the um
there is a committee meeting i believe
by the drafting
committee
next week i want to say march 7th and
8th and i apologize i'm going by memory
um
the committee that is going to be
looking at it it's the drafting
commission it's one of the drafting
commissions that's been focused on this
article 12.
so my understanding is they are going to
be meeting march 7th and 8th
and i believe they may have an april
maid um i believe they may have an april
meeting at some point and this is the
new hampshire bankers association no
this is this is the uniform law
commission okay and so i i'm relaying
information that i've been told by by
one of their members um so they'll have
the the meeting next week where they
will look at another draft amendment um
and that because i tried to get a sense
you know is there more significant more
revisions coming and it's really hard to
say because you know similar to your
process you may have an amendment that's
good to go and everyone decides they're
fine or you may look at it and say you
know so they can't
they can't tell me with any great
certainty yes this is done i think they
feel like it's close
but i don't know what that means exactly
so i understand that they've got the
meeting in march there may be a meeting
in april and i my understanding is that
it sounds like they have an annual
meeting in
june i believe where they where i would
suspect a final version would come out
so that's just my interpretation of what
i
understand to know that's happening
and if i can get the find the email i'll
try to
pin that down
you're welcome
represent has a question
thank you for your testimony uh
for participating in this uh casual
subcommittee
um
is it true that this is likely to
continuously be refined in the coming
years that
because this technology is rapidly
evolving and you know the the legal and
uh regulatory issues around it are
likely to continue to evolve to keep up
with the pace of the technology
that this is an ongoing process what
would you agree with that when you say
ongoing process are you referring to the
uniform law commission or do you mean
just overall general regulatory in the
space
i guess it could apply to both but the
language that we have before us will
continue to evolve
possibly in perpetuity as uh the
technology that it tries to advise on
also continues to evolve i can't answer
that i'm not sure i don't know how their
process works i'm assuming if things
were would continue to emerge that they
would continue to evolve that i think
that's a fair assumption but i just
don't know and haven't had those
conversations my my understanding is
that they expect adoption of an
amendment by the summer
okay
excuse me
oh john yeah you're sorry um i actually
can probably add to that because the
draft that we got the 102 page document
deals with a lot of sections other than
the new section 12. right there are a
lot of other
changes made to the code that are in
this full document right so it is they
they're looking at it all the time i'm
sure and updating it exactly
exactly
so i mean i have to agree that normally
we would wait but in this case i think
uh this is a a rare opportunity for us
to do something and have something go
forward and and if it becomes obvious
that that that there's more changes are
going to made and when this commission
comes back
then the governor can veto it
and we can we'll start start over but i
think i think
it's it's a great start and an important
thing to do
all right so uh in terms thank you chris
thank you
okay so um i guess this is the business
subcommittee so we have some changes
here who's here and who's not here
so um
so
okay so
you were chris herbert is not here
exactly and i can step in to sub for him
okay i thought you were stepping in for
abel
oh sorry you're right i guess i can't
beat two people
not easily
all right
um so said
weston and then i was going to say uh
fargo and and mclaren yep
okay
and then for our side it'll be hunt
patusek terry greeson and ammon
because johnson's missing and osborne's
missing
this is the business this is business
you're you're on you're up for this vote
you're on this vote
you're pinching okay are we voting on
the amendment first so the first motion
uh
representative ammon
uh this is on the amendment
28. how many eight
eight two eight hotel eight two eight
eight really that's what was okay
okay that's that's the amendment that's
the amendment amendment first
okay
all right so this is uh ought to pass
on the amendment
okay and so represent ammon second by
representative bartlett is that i am
understanding that correctly on the
amendment
okay all those in favor of the amendment
please raise your hand
okay
now um
representative ammon
and
seconded by
representative terry
moves ought to pass as amended
okay
is the motion clear
all right this is ought to pass
astronomy on the amendment
to 8.
yeah that that motion the amendment
passed 9-0 now we're on ought to pass as
amended
okay all those in favor raise your hand
okay and all those opposed
one two three six to three
okay
what was the
six okay thanks
all right
okay yes oh i just want to make a quick
point of information on the ucc um this
has been an ongoing it's literally a
convention of the states
uh i think it's in chicago every year
we've had over 100 of them and so
there's another committee that's always
uh
raising concerns and terrors about what
would happen in a convention of states
we've had almost 200 of these and we've
had over 200 state constitutional
conventions on top of that they're
different but
this this has been working just fine for
as long as we've been doing this and it
hasn't resulted in all the doom and
gloom that some people that that other
committee which i won't mention has been
saying so if convention of states comes
up again next session this is already
how we do it
are you talking about our constitutional
requirement over 10 years to put to the
voters whether we should have a
constitutional convention so there's a
state constitutional convention
there have been over 200 of those around
the the country uh i'm talking about our
constitution requires
that that's the state constitutional
convention okay so that's how we can get
a raise you know they did yeah if it
ever hasn't passed since 1884
but the convention of the states is
that's not true the last constant
constitutional convention new hampshire
had
was actually in the 70s
and i know this only because al jacobson
who was still around when i was get
elected he was he was a president of the
uh of the constitutional convention and
i'm trying to remember there was a
couple of articles that actually did
get passed through but
um but the state actually the voters did
actually have us go forward with a
constitutional convention in in more
modern times if i recall that but didn't
they expand the bill of rights a bit
because i saw a couple of days
i have to admit i don't remember what
but a convention of the states is
you know all 50 state legislatures we
send a delegate to orlando or something
no this is i'm talking about new
hampshire now but i'm i'm saying on the
on the
federal one yeah the ucc what i'm saying
is under article 5 of the us
constitution all 50 states each one
sends one delegate and then they discuss
the details and send it back to the
state legislatures for ratification
all right so we're breaking for lunch
and we'll see you all at 1 15.
1 15.
and we will see you at noon the gems up
in fourth floor
okay
yeah i've got to go do three things
you know but i can tell you so i mean i
can check with them
oh good okay
i have a couple errands too
so we got everybody
represented him here
i love it
okay
uh being
115 we'll get started here
uh
with the exact session we start out with
house bill 1019
where's my
is it a 10-19 yeah
so the schedule
we
do you want to go by this one or i i
usually do numeric but
um
i guess the bills were all over the
place on this one but
how to does everybody
originally
i sent a or would carry carrie sent out
all right
i have no idea where everything is on
this one
okay yep 15.95
all right
okay house bill 15
food trucks
okay
all right you know i'm sorry who would
like to make the motion on the interim
study
i had you making the motion okay perfect
all right i move interim studies second
by representative bartlett
the fundamental problem we have with the
food trucks is
that
even the sponsor on the day the bill was
introduced to the committee
came in with an amendment to have the
town the cities who still regulate food
trucks
to um have some control over the
licensure of the trucks which defeats
the whole purpose of the bill
you know if you're going to if we're
going to have the state trump
these cities then
you know how you know then say um but we
have this but we have that but
so the simple solution today is for us
to study this bill and see if there's
some way we can make that work but that
cannot happen in the short period of
time we have
so motion is interim study any questions
on the motion
yes representative
the question of the clerk uh substitutes
on the democrat side could we just
identify yourself unfortunately i'm
sorry um i thought representative
herbert was coming i just texted him and
i have not received a
reply linda tanner
but representative linder tanner is
ready substituting for um representative
boglio billio
okay
all right
motion's clear clerk will call the role
on interim study
interim study house bill 1595
representative patosik yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative hamm
representative acton yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative bartlett
and i skipped over representative terry
bartlett yes
representative abel
yes
representative herbert
not here uh he's not here okay
representative van houten yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes
representative tanner
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcelroy yes
representative hunt yes so 18 to 0. well
those in favor of placing 15.95 in the
consent calendar please say aye aye
those opposed so move unanimously
okay
next up
10.95 relative to the sale of fresh
condiments on push cards selling
frankfurters and pre-cooked sausages
um what we have discovered on 1095 is
that
the sponsor's request was for chili dogs
and
we have found that it is possible
that he can have his chili dog if the
push cart vendor
buys those pre-made little chili
pre-made chili things i think campbell's
makes them and
jenny moore makes them they're they're
single serving things so as long as
they're in their single serving
packaging then they can be sold on the
push cart so he can have his
chili dog
so at this point we're
so now i'm i'm confused
motion is itl and
um right mabel made the emotion
what's that representative abel made the
motion represented able seconded by
representative
abramson
moves itl
any discussion on the motion
see none oh representative abramson has
actually a question i did
uh so i obviously agreed with the intent
of the bill which was allowing the sale
fresh condiments such as sauerkraut
chile
and so on and so forth yes
so you're saying that the solution is
that they sell the prepaid packets yes
and that you don't didn't want state
licensing of people having the little
you know push things
so you can get sauerkraut you can get
mustard you can get onions you can get
chili
in a pre-paid in a pre-made package so
the push cart has it on the pack on that
and they're all set
maybe you don't want to second the
motion of itl
oh i didn't know that
well i saw your hand up so i was
concerned it was just okay all right
representative
okay any more discussion on the itl
motion
seeing on the oh yeah so that was second
about patusek
okay
okay the clerk call the roll
representative patusik
yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
aye
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett yes representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes representative
weston yes representative bill you
oh sorry representative tanner
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes representative
hunt yes 18-0
okay
all those in favor placing uh 1095 on
the consent calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
okay
all right 10 43 establishing a committee
to study regulations applicable to small
businesses that sell food
okay uh
representative patusek seconded
by representative hunt
moves in expedient to legislate
you want to speak to your motion
okay
any discussion on the motion of anything
to legislate
enough already
seen on the clerk we'll call the roll
i'm sorry what's the bill number on this
1043.
is ito representative patusik
uh yes
representative osborne yes
clark votes yes representative abramson
aye rose of ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes rosa johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett yes representative abel
yes representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston
representative tanner
representative burroughs yes
representative mclean yes representative
hunt yes 18-0
okay all those in favor placing it on
the consent calendar say aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
okay
1503 exempting the developer selling of
facilitating or exchange of an open
block token for certain security laws
okay representative ammon seconded by
representatives moves out to pass on the
amendment
the amendment number
i'll have it here
day 28 that sounds familiar
zero eight what was the amendment number
eight two eight
and
represent em and you're recognized to
speak to the motion
thank you mr chair
house bill 1503 is going to put new
hampshire at
not the bleeding edge of new technology
but certainly at the forefront of
adopting
rules around digital assets
that were worked on for
at least
two years by the univer universal law
commission so we're in a unique
opportunity to
um
adopt something
and be uh
be one of the first states to do it
and uh it marries nicely with the
governor's commission on digital assets
so
uh please support the ultipass motion on
this amendment
representative weston do you want to
speak to it
okay
all right that's right this is the
amendment okay
okay
uh the
motion is not to pass on the amendment
clerk will call the roll
representative patusik yes
representative osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative abramson aye
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes representative
weston yes representative tanner
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mccleary yes
representative hunts yes 18 to zero okay
now the pending motion is ought to pass
as amended from representative ammon
seconded by representative patusek
is there any discussion on the motion of
octopass as amended representative
weston oh you know what
all right thank you thank you mr chair
um uh although i do i did support the
amendment i am not in support of the
bill as it stands amended because i
think
for a number of reasons one is that i
think it would be a good idea for us to
wait until we get the results of the
governor's commission which will be
coming in on august 8th
i think also that
this is not necessarily a place where
new hampshire wants to be first in the
nation
i think it's a very risky industry
and uh
i do agree with the first part of the
bill that um
you know if we're
dealing with cryptocurrencies
the part of um
exempting them from the securities law
is fine but i don't agree necessarily
that we want to put ourselves out
as first in the nation to open ourselves
up to this industry so i have to stand
on my principles on this
and um and
take it from there thank you
anybody else like to speak on the
octopus as amended representative
abramson uh yeah it's just a quick point
uh
or two quick points one is it
it i didn't view this as a security i
viewed this as more of a key so it's
rather than investing or putting your
money in a bank or a mutual fund it'd be
more like likening to a key for a safe
deposit box
um so it's not that you're putting money
into somebody else's hands for them to
go out and invest or loan to other
people so it didn't do it as a security
i viewed this as
um
creating a clear path after the fact not
to deal with the sick the the you know
the cryptocurrency or the bitcoin itself
but to deal with if there are
allegations of fraud or some other
activity to enable the courts to to go
do this and and i think there were some
very bright people in the ucc who went
over all these issues already and i'm
certainly expect
the other states to implement this
representative
this legislation is not radical
legislation this is pretty middle of the
road legislation
and
you know i think
as we get ahead here a few years looking
back on this moment i think
you'll see that new hampshire's making
the right
decision
at this point in time thank you
okay any more discussion on the motion
about the pastors amended yes
representative bartlett thank you mr
chair um i have to say that
i have been on the fence on this one
um while
i don't think that
cryptocurrency is always used for
transparent
reasons
npr had an article this morning on
how the russian oligarchs are trying to
change their rubles that are worth very
little right now into
cryptocurrency
i am going to
i am going to support the otpa because i
do feel that there are some guardrails
on this it does not mean we have to go
forward
with the cryptocurrency in new hampshire
though i do recognize
it is being used in new hampshire now
therefore i will support the otpa
but it is with some reluctant reluctance
representation
yeah thank you for that sentiment um
again i mentioned earlier that any
technology can be used for good and it
can also be used for bad purposes so a
counterpoint to the russian oligarchs
using it if you go on the government of
ukraine's official twitter page
and you scroll down a few tweets you'll
see that they're soliciting bitcoin
donations they have a bitcoin address
and they use it for night vision goggles
and for
bulletproof vests and you can send
without any intermediary from your
smartphone right now directly to the
ukrainian government to support their
their efforts fighting the russians so
that's an example of it being used i
think for a good purpose
thank
you anyone else
yes mr chair i believe that this is a
unique opportunity for the state of new
hampshire to take a leadership position
across all 50 states
and we will have a lot of states
following our lead after we get this as
a law thank you
okay
any more discussion seeing none the
clerk will call the role and not to pass
as amended
representative patusik yes
representative osborne yes clerk votes
yes representative abramson aye
representative ham
representative acton yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel no
representative van houghton no
representative fargo no
representative weston
representative tanner
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear
yes
representative hunts yes
14 to four
okay 14 to four
then i assume there'll be a minority
report yeah great
interim study
cheers choices
okay
at least we'll have one bill on the
regular calendar
okay
uh
1140's relative condo instruments and
condo special assessments
uh anybody like to make the motion on
itl
okay
and seconded by representative patusek
i'm sorry who made the mission weston
okay
would you like to speak to your motion
please
this is the 60 to get a budget
to override the
budget yes
no well it's not special this is the
budget it's not just special yeah it's
the budget thank you thank you for the
prompt
sorry about that um yeah this would
really hamstring the the boards the
condo boards um that often have to make
a special assessment when something goes
wrong like you know
a roof leaks or something along that
line there are
i think that in general they're very
reasonable about
spending money and not being foolish
about it so
we don't want to hamstring
the boards also it would make it very
difficult to get anybody to run for a
board so i think this should be itled
okay any more discussion on any speeding
to legislate seeing none the clerk will
call the roll
representative
yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
aye
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett
yes
representative abel
representative van halton yes
representative fargo yes representative
weston yes representative tanner
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mcelroy yes
representative hunt yes 18-0 all those
in favor placing 1146 on the consent
calendar please say aye aye those
opposed
so moved unanimously
okay 1380 relative installation of solar
photovoltaic energy systems by owners
subject to deed restrictions and a
homeowners association i have 12 49 next
mr chair 12.
sorry i didn't like doing it this way
okay
1380 is what i have next
so
1380 this is
connie's bill
[Laughter]
which i'm not recognizing for the motion
okay
um i'll i'll move it that's fine
it's second by representative patusek
the next legislate
um i think we had a good discussion good
conversation and
at the end of the day um when you buy a
condo you better read the
fine print
and know what you're getting yourself
into and uh if you want to be into solar
make sure your neighbors are just as
solar oriented as you are
representative anthony uh you just use
the trigger word that that makes me want
to respond there are some misperceptions
about this bill one is that it's not
economy oh that's right you're right it
is uh for homeowners associations in
which people actually own their roofs
own their lots on which they can make
these installations and so i think
that's something that should be
considered as you vote regardless of how
you vote i also want to stipulate that
this is not a mandate it is enabling
legislation
the localities the the cities and towns
would have to
enter have an inter intervening vote for
that so there's no mandate involved here
and just very quickly
um see some people seem to think that
the deeds would have to be rewritten or
that other docs would have to be or
documents would have to be rewritten and
that's not the case
the legislation as it's written would
just nullify any kind of reference to
installation the photovoltaic systems so
with that
i hope you'll consider my constituents
and others across the state
for whom
obviously solar energy can be clean
efficient safe
and something of the future that we can
implement today
i don't mean today as in now obviously
because it has to have the enabling
legislation element beyond but i hope
you consider that thank you
representative abramson um i agreed with
the overall concept of the bill but i'm
not voting for the
the bill and the the
the reason is the structure of it when
we get bills that we agree with but we
we can't
go back to all the stakeholders so i
think it would be worth bringing it back
in
next year but i don't think we need to
refer for interim study i think we need
to send the sponsors back
and the the particular issue that i had
was in line two
that a restriction shall be considered
unreasonable for the purpose of this
section that's come up in both criminal
and civil law where the legislature just
declares something
without both sides being able to contest
the issue in court
whether or not something is reasonable
has to be decided in the case by case
basis for for a judge in my opinion um
and and looked at by the courts so
in a nutshell that's my the reason that
i'm against it but i would be willing to
work in the future to put together
something different
there you go okay
someone to work with okay the motion is
inexpensive to legislate any more
discussion on the motion scene on the
clerk we'll call the role representative
patousik yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
aye representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
no
representative van houghton no
representative fargo yes
representative weston
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear no
representative hunts
yes
14 to 4.
uh i'm sorry nevermind
okay
uh uh that's too many for consent is
there gonna be a minority report
yes okay
van houghton
and what's the motion
ultra pass
about to pass
okay
all right next up is uh
1378 relative to inspection of public
lodging and housing
actually it was interesting the the the
bill had had one point of view but it
opened up a huge can of worms when we
realized how old the statute was and how
cumbersome
it is and given that the it was
referring to
registration the registrar's which i
don't think i've seen one of those in a
hotel
it's not even a bed and breakfast i
don't think i've ever seen a registrar
anymore i mean they're the age gone by i
think privacy keeps away from seeing
that so people don't see the names but
at any rate um the the better part of
this bill is needs to be studied more so
who would like to make the interim study
motion
okay representative johnson seconded by
representative terry
from interim study
any discussion on the motion of interim
study
um sorry i missed the bill number again
1378.
i can't
all right it's the motion clear clerk
will call the roll
representative
yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
aye
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett yes representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes
representative tanner
representative burrows yes
representative mclear yes representative
hunt
yes
18 to zero
okay all those in favor placing 1370 on
the consent calendar please say aye hi
those opposed
cash
all right
i need to take one break here
you're out of oh you know because i
stole some of your forms didn't i
yeah yeah all right so we'll have a
brief recess here
so is the next one 12.49
whatever it takes for him to get forms
printed
is
yeah no i'm just feeling a little cool
today yeah are you
it's a little it just seemed a little
warmer
that's old
she's coming i'll use the back of it
oh you you didn't get extra ones or
she's she i just ran into her she's
12 49.
okay
house bill 1249 relative to weights and
measures
representative hunt moves to ought to
pass
second by representative patusek
uh so uh the great thing about this
committee we learned something new every
day and we learned about high
precision weights and measures that we
have here in the state
most of it was over my head but
this uh is brings us in line with the
current practices of these scales
see any other discussion on the motion
about to pass
okay the clerk will call the role on uh
to
pass
representative patusik yes
representative osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative abramson
representative hamm representative acton
yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
yes
representative van houten yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes
representative tanner
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer yes
representative hunts yes
18 to 0. all those in favor placing in
1249 on the consent calendar please say
aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
all right 1404 relative to consumer
rights regarding towing of vehicles
who would like to uh
make the motion of itl i have
representative weston down
okay
all right representative weston seconded
by representative patousek moves in
expedient to legislate
the representative western is recognized
to speak to our motion sure um this bill
would put specific limits on tow
companies so that um there are
situations where they may lose money on
towing a vehicle not all vehicles cost
the same to tow
like the difference between trucks and
cars
it also sets up a situation where the
tow company might not be available if
for a call if they're
dealing with this particular
situation
um
so
so we we just felt that it would
put the business of private property tow
vehicles uh private towing companies out
of business if we were to pass this
legislation
so i think it should be inexpedient to
legislate
and the sponsor urges us to kill it
yes that's right the sponsor also felt
it should be itl so thank you
okay any more discussion on the motion
of any speed to legislate religiously
this
clerk will call the roll
house bill 1404 itl
uh representative patusik yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
aye representative ham representative de
palma
i'm sorry
it's a new sheet
representative acton
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett yes
representative abel
yes
herbert's not here representative van
houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes representative
tanner
yes
representative burroughs
representative mclear yes
representative hunt yes 18-0
well those in favor are placing
14 13. excuse me 1404 on the consent
calendar please say aye
that was opposed
so moved unanimously
okay
relative to consumer right fourteen
thirteen that's it fourteen thirteen two
small the print here yeah fourteen
thirteen relative to privacy online
customer information
uh who would like to make the itl motion
representative westin yes i move that we
itl second by representative patusek
and you recognize to speak to your
motion um although i recognize the good
intent of this bill we found that the um
that it was really targeting the problem
from the wrong angle
it was targeting the internet service
providers the isps
that really don't have any access to
your personal information
it also conflicts with federal law that
already
holds isps to account for personal
commitments
and there's a bill in maine that passed
in 2019 that is now
being
[Music]
it's
is
now the subject of go on
i'm sorry
yeah ongoing legislation
thank you
so we decided that um the the problem of
privacy needs needs to be addressed at
the federal level and that this should
be itled
thanks whatever
okay any other representative abramson
um i disagreed with on this bill on both
the itl and otp so i'm not going to vote
with i'm not voting with the itl motion
and
even though the the bill had um some
issues that i didn't agree with the
underlying
idea that your internet service provider
would take
information that that they'd gathered
from you um and sell it i didn't i
advocate of privacy and also the voters
by a margin of i think ten to one passed
that uh
you know constitutional amendment
amendment to the state constitution
protecting privacy so i felt that it was
serious enough issue to hold on to the
bill
okay
any other discussion on the motion
of any speeding to legislate saying none
the clerk will call the roll
representative
yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
no
representative ham representative acton
yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
yes representative abel
yes
representative van halton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes
representative hunts yes
17 to one
okay are you all right with consent um
i'd like to write a minority report okay
so that will stay on the regular
calendar and motion is
oh um i don't have an amendment so i'd
have to say ought to pass even though
you could say interim study
um
i how do i put this that's right i'll
say my suggestions ought to pass okay
even though i would ought to pass with
amendment
okay
all right next up 1422 requiring warning
labels on consumer products containing
perforated chemicals
pfas all right
got mclear
macular
yes you have a motion uh yes uh motion
to itl okay there was an immaculate
second by representative patusek moves
in explaining to legislate
any discussion on the motion
just you know comment uh you know this
is an important uh discussion in the
future unfortunately uh every other
product on the shelf has uh uh some of
these these chemicals in them and it's
just a little bit uh
overwhelming to try to get everybody to
do it apparently maine has passed a law
i don't think we really know how that's
turned out so i think this is just uh
not
his time is not ready thank you and we
we also did already pass a subcommittee
a study committee on this issue i was
just going to mention that yes
okay
see no more discussion wheel the clerk
will call the role of out to pass excuse
me any speed to legislation on 1422.
representative petuck yes representative
osborne yes clerk votes yes
representative abramson aye
representative ham
representative uh representative acton
yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer yes
representative hunt yes 18-0
all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
1559 relative laws administered by the
insurance department
representative bartlett
uh thank you um this is an otp
um i think we i'm let's see i guess i'm
a prime sponsor
um
this was requested by the insurance
department there are a number of um not
to pass by representative bartlett
seconded by representative
you're recognized to speak to your
motion okay um
this was um
requested by the insurance department
there are a number of um technical well
ols calls it a
technical change but
it's not strictly technical because of
the different areas that they needed to
clean up
it adds clarifying language in a number
of places it specifies an agent's
referral fee to 25 it adds rulemaking
authority for paid family medical leave
allows reduced premiums during
extenuating circumstances
allows for notice provisions of a third
party when insured cancels a commercial
policy and adds language to explain the
process for liens on property in the
continuing care retirement community
statute
great
any discussion on the motion about to
pass seeing on the click will call the
roll
patosik yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
aye representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett
yes
representative abel yes representative
van hatten yes representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mcelier yes
representative hunt yes 18-0 all those
in favor placing the consent calendar
please say aye
those opposed so mood unanimously
okay
representative barley also take 1558
relative insurance holding companies
second representative batusec
representative bartlett is recognized to
speak to our motion and thank you mr
chair um this bill also was requested by
the insurance department it incorporates
updates into the insurance model act
regarding receiverships and group
capital
calculation for credit for reinsurance
this is naic model legislation
great any more discussion on the motion
of what to pass seeing none the clerk
will call the roll and he's ready
representative patusik yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative hamm
representative acton
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes
representative herbert sorry he's not
here representative of manhattan yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes representative
tanner yes representative burroughs yes
representative mcelroy yes
representative hans yes
18-0 all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
okay
1019 establishing a committee to study
the replacement of certain professional
licenses with mandatory minimum
liability insurance requirement
representative abramson second by
representative patusek moves interim
study uh representative abramson you're
recognized to speak to your motion
uh in a uh
in a nutshell i'm gonna go on because
we've got a lot of bills but in a
nutshell professional licensing has been
a very big issue
um the notion of reducing minimizing
government regulations and licensing and
red tape is part of the new hampshire
republican platform so it's kind of come
up
over and over again
but in a greater sense we've gone from
um
i think it might have been afp
mentioned that we've gone from eight
percent of workers having to get an
occupational license now it's gone up to
30 it looks like it's just going up and
up and up
and there was a study done um
that showed that professional licensing
was one of the major
um unmentioned causes or contributors to
poverty and limiting income mobility so
for that reason felt that there were
a lot of reasons to want to open this up
and felt that it needed a lot more time
than just a hearing so for that reason i
wanted to refer foreign representative
bartlett
thank you mr chair
um if you have an issue regarding
uh professional licensing that's one
thing but the idea of replacing it with
the minimum liability insurance um is
there you're talking about apples and
oranges so um for that reason i would be
opposing the interim steady and
in favor of an itl
okay
any other yeah representative van gaal
thank you um the prevailing motion is
interim study
the pending motion motion yes sir thank
you
um it i it just strikes me that it's
it's a counter-intuitive to interim
study something to study something
and i i would prefer then the itl motion
fair enough
any more discussion on the motion of
interim studies saying none the clerk
will call the role
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
uh aye representative ham
representative acton yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett no
representative abel no
representative van houghton no
representative fargo
representative weston no representative
tanner no
representative burroughs
representative mcleary no
representative hunts
yes
it doesn't matter okay
i'll do the minority report
minority report okay
okay
no it's interim study
and minority rep from violet so justin
aside that certainly was um different
than the six to zero subcommittee it
certainly was wasn't it yes it was
let's do another one
uh
1048 relative to minimum non-fortunate
amounts under the standard and
unfortunate law for individual deferred
annuities
representative mcaleer
moves ought to pass second
any more discussion on the motion about
to pass
okay kirk will call the roll
representative
yes representative osborne
hi
representative ham representative acton
yes representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett yes representative abel yes
representative van halton yes
representative fargo representative
weston yes representative tanner
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mcelroy yes
representative hunt yes 18-0
okay all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye does
opposed so move unanimously
yes
um
i've got a question on uh
hb
1019 who seconded that i did not hear a
second
oh i can tell you uh
representative patusek
yeah
thank you
okay
1582 repealing the granite state paid
family leave plan
representative johnson second by
representative patusek moves interim
study
any need for a discussion yes
i just wanted to mention that there was
uh it was noted that this is also in
labor correct and that's so why would we
not kill one of those two bills uh
because we'll
we let them decide what they're going to
do and we'll just keep keep ours alive
if
we want it
stay tuned
any more discussion on the motion of
interim study yes
representative abrams yeah actual
parliamentary inquiry if um
if you have two committees with a bill
aren't we in a better position just kind
of holding on to our bills so we're not
unless there's not a deadline on this
particular bill we could just recess
the this bill until
the end of uh no there is a deadline and
i mean there's both bills have to get
out at the same time
okay
so okay the motion is interim study
the click will call the role
representative
yes representative osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative abramson
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
yes representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes representative
hunt yes
18-0 all those in favor of placing 1582
on the consent calendar please say aye
those opposed so move nina ashley
okay
1613 establishing a limited farmer's
liquor manufacturer's license
we have an amendment for this bill
i guess
okay so i'll make the motion
second by representing patusek
and this takes the place of the and this
will replace 0.450.
replace the entire bill
um
not that i have anything against farmers
but i i we want to be fair to everyone
and what this bill does will will reduce
the fee
for someone who wants to do a small
batch
of distilled liquor
okay any discussion on the motion about
to pass on the amendment can we just see
the difference between what the other
amendment was offering and what this
one's offering
well she she the sponsor had come in
with another amendment that
kind of
i don't know shuffle the chairs on the
titanic but didn't really
get a yeah but she she had a heart
set on doing something for farmers
right
but this one okay so this isn't
necessarily farmers it's just anybody
and everybody
is that if you're going to
if you're going to do a less than a
thousand cases
then
then why pay
a license of 1
okay why not have a cheap old license of
300 bucks let's see my notes show that
um aidan moore was here
opposing the original
right the original because it was not
enforceable
yeah because all that the whole farmer's
requirement was don't believe a new
license for farmers only
uh an approach that would be involved
here approach
so has
aiden seen this oh yeah aiden wrote it
he wrote it okay you don't think i go
anywhere else so right have to write an
amendment written
one stop shopping
he's downstairs with
the marijuana
okay any other discussion on the motion
about to pass on the amendment see none
of the click will call the roll
me
ought to pass on amendment h 830h
house bill 1613 representative
yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett yes
representative abel
yes representative van halton yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes representative
tanner
yes
representative burroughs
representative mclear yes
representative hunt yes 18-0
okay
all those uh the motion now is uh
representative hunt secondary
representative patusek ought to pass as
amended
is there any discussion on the motion
scene then the clerk will call the role
representative
yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative hamm
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
yes
representative van halton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcelier yes
representative hunts yes
18 0.
okay all those in favor placing it on
the consent calendar please say aye
those opposed
so move unanimously
okay next is uh house bill 1556 relative
to on-premise off-premise sales of
beverage manufacturer facilities
and
this one is uh okay so this one we were
able to resolve this is the bill where
it turns out that if you have a multiple
licenses
then
it seemed it appeared to some
licensees who had these multiple
licenses that they had to have two
separate point-of-sale systems
and um after a discussion with the
liquor commission
um they realized that then maybe there
was some confusion out there about what
was going on
and they have sent out a bulletin
to all licensees to assure them that as
long as their software can handle
separate sales which of course it can i
mean that would be a pretty clunky
software if it can't and uh but that as
long as they're able to do that then
they would um they they're in compliance
and
this bill would not be necessary however
we always want to keep an eye on the
liquor commission so i'm recommending
that we enter and study this bill and
discuss it come
next uh
september justin made assured the
bulletin was fulfilled and also there
was another request of another side
issue that was
so much remained
so we'll take that up in september when
we interim study the bill so
representative hunt secondary
representative
moo's
interim study
representative pilot
thanks mr chair um yeah i think that
it makes sense to put this into an
interim study we did have
testimony from a number of business
owners
that
were getting some
contradictory
messages from it sounded like one
particular auditor
so i think if we can keep this
at least open enough to hear from
constituents or maybe we want to follow
up with them to find out if in fact it
has changed
um
i think that makes sense good
representative i thought you said you
weren't going to talk too much today no
i don't talk too much okay okay i just
wanted to remind members of the
committee that i did have legislative
services
put a proposed amendment if you want
language in front of you
so i just emailed it to all members of
the committee it was dealing with
after researching this found there were
some areas where the person handing you
the bottle at
different locations could be 14 15 16 18
so that's why i felt like it needed
some time
okay so that would be another issue
we'll take up in september
okay
all right the motion of interim study
clerk will call the role
house bill 1556 interim study
representative yes representative
osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative abramson
representative ham
representative de palma
representative
you can see how my brain works right
it's like
representative acton yes representative
greeson
representative johnson
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcelroy yes and
representative hunts yes
18 0.
okay all those in favor of placing the
consent calendar please say aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
okay next up 1039 relative the
definition of a beverage manufacturer
retail outlet
representative hunt second by
representative patusik moves ought to
pass on the amendment
for those who have in front of you
what's the amendment number oh here it
is okay
it's 0 2 8 4.
how's that number so
yeah because i i did this
i introduced this amendment at the
hearing if you might remember
okay so the underlying bill was to deal
with the issue to clarify even though
the attorney general did take a position
but it clarified that the previous
legislation that we passed
relative to a
beverage manufacturer having a second
location that this clarifies that they
do not need to manufacture
at that location
what this amendment does is then carry
on to
we'll dare to call housekeeping measures
of the liquor commission
um one was it turns out that a little uh
glitch in the
in the john hunt memorial direct
shipping law where the the law said
within a 90-day period
and the 90-day period was then used as
so that means i just lose my license for
90 days and then you have to give it
back to me 90 days from after
which is not exactly what we intended to
do
so with that this will remove that
90-day period
statement in the loss of licensure
the other issue came up was that um
at one point in time uh the the previous
audit done to the liquor commission was
why didn't the liquor commission offer
multi-year licenses
so
the liquor commission duly came in and
they added multi-year licenses
to the statute and
now five years later have discovered
that not a single licensee has ever
requested a multi-year license and so
the next audit that the looking
commission went through they suggested
it be repealed and that's why it's in
this amendment
any discussion on the amendment
see none the clerk will call the roll
house bill 1039 also pass amendment
284-h representative patousik yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative ham
representative acton
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel yes representative
van halton
representative fargo
representative weston yes representative
tanner yes representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer yes
representative hunt yes 18-0
okay representative hunt second baby
representative patuck moves out to pass
as amended
any discussion on the motion seeing none
the clerk will call the roll
representative patusik yes
representative osborne clerk votes yes
representative abramson
representative hamm
representative acton
representative greeson representative
johnson
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclean yes representative
hunt yes 18-0
all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye
those opposed
so move unanimously
okay
all right
last liquor bill uh hb 1583
uh
relative to location and days of
operation of state liquor stores
representative hunt second
representative patusek moves out to pass
on the amendment
zero eight three eight
okay so if you'll recall this bill uh
had um
several parts in it uh
the first two sections were related um
to
locate locating the
uh where the liquor stores can be
um
but the one that everybody we all we had
most attention on to was the
sunday and holiday opening section of
the bill
and uh the question of being um
was uh easter
uh i guess we all pretty much in general
agree that that's a good idea probably
be closed for thanksgiving and christmas
day
but after going through it and trying to
you know like
you know trying to decide whether easter
is is important or
maybe adding
passover i don't know because that you
know we could could go either way
then and i took one different look at it
i said well why don't we just if the
first sentence says the liquor
commission can make this decision in its
destruction
and it really is
based if you read in the later part of
the bill it's it's their ability to
actually find employees who are willing
to work those days
uh for the commission even decide
whether they're going to be open those
days
so i decided that wouldn't it be easier
just to get rid of all those
particular holidays
and
and the commission if they can you know
if they think they can find employees
who want to work on thanksgiving or
christmas
then you know all the power to them but
not that i think that'll happen but
um at least at least the law is
consistent by not picking
favorites when it comes to holidays
representative abramson
so i
as i've
said before i didn't agree with the just
the whole notion of
you know i i've never liked the idea of
the state operating state liquor stores
but just in particular having the state
decide and having the legislature decide
that we'll it will allow the
liquor stores to be open on christmas
day and easter and thanksgiving which
are kind of the three days where you
really expect things to be closed we
used to have blue laws
in new hampshire that said that you know
sunday mornings you're supposed to be
you know either at church or home with
your family um and those were repealed a
couple of years ago
because no town was really following
them but this it just it kind of made me
feel uncomf
uncomfortable and a little bit odd
that we were gonna pass legislation to
just have the liquor stores be open on
on the three holiest
um days of the year and i know for sure
that i'm gonna be hearing about this
when i go back to seabrook
well i don't know that their liquor
stores will be open in seabrook those
days
representative bartlett i think you make
a good point mr chair i think um if you
go back to seabrook and tell them that
they are going to be open that days you
would be incorrect this bill is only
saying that at liquor stores at their
discretion can do it and they've still
got to find people that are work so i
think it's very unlikely that they're
going to be open um the days that you're
concerned about
so well
we're trying to clean up the statute to
have less regulations
less
less regulations
well who's that way we all can say
you're not always consistent are you
every other bill
right well i do find it ironic that of
course you can always buy beer at the
convenience store
or wine any time you want
on any day of the year
okay
any discussion on the motion about to
pass on the amendment
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
amendment eight three eight h
representative patousik representative
osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative abramson
representative hamm
representative acton
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yeah representative
bartlett
yes representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes representative
weston yes
representative tanner yes representative
burroughs
representative mceldeer yes
representative hunt yes
17 to max
okay the motion is ought to pass as
amended
is there any discussion on the motion
see none the clerk will call the roll
it's haunted sick is there right yes
unless anybody else wants to write the
player
representative
yes representative osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative abramson
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yeah representative
bartlett
yes representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes representative
hans yes 17-1
will there be a minority report
okay
and it's um
what's your motion yeah what would be
your motion
okay this is 15.
okay
all right uh
10 28 relative to the form of individual
health insurance policies
oh god here we go again
[Laughter]
look
representative abramson
moves second by representation moves out
to pat no excuse me interim study intro
study
interim study on
uh 10 28. representative abramson's
recognized to speak to his motion
so um
this
is also a republican platform bill
and it touched on several different
planks in the republican platform
so that was one side of it yet the other
issue is the rising health care costs
aren't just taking a lot of money out of
our pocket but our constituents pockets
um costs have been going up at i think
seven or eight or nine percent per year
um
and we we have this you know this is a
committee where we have to do do
something about it and really dig into
the details of the details in order to
figure out how to get costs down
and then the last part was
that when i've gone to when i was on my
the town's budget committee and we're
looking at what's driving up our
property taxes by far the number one
issue was rising health care costs so we
needed i felt that we needed to really
dig into this
and look at ways to open up health care
to competition
and so for that reason i felt that we
needed to put more time
into health care issues and insurance
but especially health insurance issues
okay
any discussion on the motion of interim
i mean
representative parliament
i'm shaking my head because i thought
this was going to be your opportunity to
talk about insurance 101.
yes we could do that
um i
would have a tough time supporting an
interim study on this one i probably
will but i'm not going to like it
um
uh
i am i also take issue with the idea
that insurance premiums have been going
up seven eight and nine percent per year
we do have mr brandon here with us from
the insurance department and maybe he
could speak to the kind of increases
that um insurance has been
um
we'll get that we'll get there when they
get to this okay okay
never mind
yeah that'll be i'm i'm willing to
tolerate this motion in the sense that
that obviously
we have a lot of new members on
republican side on this committee who
really don't have learned
why
you know why why insurance is what it is
and how we got here and understand what
the short-term policy was i mean it was
very nice that tyler mailed it out to
everybody and i'm sure
representative abramson read it
what he was sent and knowing how
the short-term policies are de minimis
and violate the
uh the affordable care act uh other than
the extent that the affordable care act
is tolerated
that it would be a six month only
probably a six month with i don't know
or three months with one renewal was
that it was something like that
but at any rate
if people we we
it's worth having something to
understand why health insurance is what
it is and this is a good vehicle to do
that with
any more discussion on the motion of
interim study representative van helm
thank you um i'm probably going to vote
i actually will vote for the interim
study although my preference is the itl
i'm just i just have a concern that we
that we represent
our entire state and talk about
platforms as being a reason to make a
vote
regardless of which side you're on and i
just wanted to register that concern
thank you fair enough
representative abel
yes i oppose this bill and i will be
voting against it
this is offering
insurance that doesn't
have adequate coverage and we should not
be doing that
okay representative greeson
thank you mr chair i see this as an
opportunity whether or not short-term
insurance is anything anybody wants to
buy
is is uh is immaterial to me but i see
this as being an opportunity to at least
begin the discussion of
uh we need something to compete against
subsidized insurance
okay
the motion clear the clerk will call the
roll
representative
yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative hamm
representative acton yes
representative greeson
representative johnson yes
representative terry
represented bartlett
reluctantly yes
representative abel no
representative van houten
reluctantly also yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston no
representative
tanner
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer no
representative hans yes
15-3
okay
would there be a minority report
all right
with your minority motion
thank you
okay
uh
yeah lemon hp 1162.
representative greeson seconded by
representative patusek who's interim
study
representative greeson recognized to
speak to your motion
there is concern
that
if somebody receives a
vaccine or medication or uses a device
of any kind
that has not been officially approved by
the fda
but is allowed to be used under
emergency use authorization that an
insurance company may not
cover
any
adverse reaction or effect
to that
device or treatment or vaccine or
medication
and so this bill was uh
was intended to require them
to cover any said side effects
i don't think there's
comfort
a settled this that that actually they
will cover it supposedly they would
but if we put it to interim study this
gives us an opportunity to
at least be able to
do a little bit more digging into what
exactly insurance companies are required
to cover
for emergency youth use authorization
medications and any effects that might
be
as a result of that
i think there's a greater problem or
risk that goes beyond the scope of this
legislation
but at least as far as this is concerned
i think that's the aim of it and i think
we can look into it
just to make sure that yes indeed
they are covering it we'll cover it and
if we need to pass them that requires
them then that would be down the road
okay any other discussion on the motion
of in interim study
seeing on the clerk will call the roll
representative
yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative ham
representative acton
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
no
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcelroy yes
and representative hunts
yes
17 to one
okay um
you all ready to put on the consent
calendar rich
sure okay all those in favor please
consent calendar please say yes
yes those who do not post say no
okay
so that was
11 62.
okay
uh
12 45 relative co-payments for services
rendered by a chiropractor
representative johnson she loves her
chiropractor
moves interim study
i'm seconded by representative terry
everson johnson would you like to talk
about this bill
sure
um i just feel that we maybe just need
to look into this to make sure that
we're
we're not overstepping because i i do
think it's between the insurance
and the doctors but i want to make sure
that everybody's we're looking into it
in a proper way
great any more discussion on interim
study
for 12 45
see none the clerk will call the role
representative patosik
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative ham
representative acton
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry representative
bartlett yes
representative abel yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes
representative hunt yes
18-0 all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye aye
those opposed some moved asleep
okay 1501 relative insurance coverage
for pediatric audio moon
neuropsychiatric
disorders
uh
okay yeah so this the sunset's not going
to happen for a couple years so uh
i i moved to
uh make this bill in expedition to
legislate
yeah
and representative bartlett's recognized
to speak to our motion thank you mr
chair um a subcommittee came out of this
interim study because we did feel that
it was important that this be
that the message be sent to anybody um
in oh you're right i had did i do it
wrong now i believe that it was in our
study six to zero
okay i'm sorry okay good thank you
interim study
representative bartlett seconded by
representative heinrich's interim study
okay
all right
so any discussion on the interim study
motion
seeing on the clerk we'll call the role
representative
yes representative
osborne clerk votes yes representative
abramson
representative ham
representative acton yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett
yes representative abel
yes
representative van halton yes
representative fargo
representative weston yeah
representative tanner yes representative
burroughs
representative mcelier
yes representative hunts
yes 18-0
all those in favor placing on consent
calendar please say aye
that was opposed to move unanimously
all right last but not least
uh 1580 relative to pharmacy benefit
managers
representative bartlett
seconded by representatives
in expedia to legislate
representative bartlett is recognized to
speak to her motion
yes this is something that we have
discussed over the years
um things have changed over the last
few years and many of the
pharmacy benefit managers are now
employees of the insurance carriers
it is an opaque
relationship
but i don't think licensing is going to
make
any difference
on whether we can
determine the price of drugs
okay any other discussion on the motion
of
an expanding to legislate saying none
the clerk will call the roll
representative patousik yes
representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative abramson
representative hamm
representative acton
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett yes
representative
i abstain on this one
i'm going to vote no there you go
representative van houghton
yes
representative fargo
representative weston yes
representative tanner yes
representative burroughs
representative mcelroy yes
representative hans yes
16 to two
okay the two are you guys
consent
okay all those in favor of consent
please say aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
and we are adjourned from our exact
session
you